you want to hear whack pack summer
update let me do let me get you i pitch
eric believe it or not has become high
society in a sense his money from cameo
has catapulted him into a whole other
class of lifestyle this is maybe the
most mind-blowing thing you're going to
hear on the show today eric spent his
summer playing golf with his rich
friends and smoking expensive cigars
golf eric uh what are you smoking there
pal i smoke on a rocky patel italian
sets by 60.
excellent how was the flavor on this the
flavor is very good it's
it's like a
dos cigar it's from honduras
and it's a great flavor
and it's like a hint of espresso because
it's a dark cigar
and it goes good ones right with the
bourbon
wow eric's like gone into like like a
whole life who is he playing golf with
who's who are his girlfriends i think oj
[Laughter]
uh asked napkin ed you were asking me
what happened to him this summer
yes always worry about him here's the
highlight well i blew a fire and chipped
my pants while i was walking to the
store for a sub i thought i was gonna
blow a [ __ ] fart and then instead of
the jews came out instead is that a
situation where it dripped down your
legs there was a ton of it kind of
spilling out under the ground and [ __ ]
my boots were wet my sacks were wet so i
had to let them dry out turns out ed's
whole summer plan was just to be gross
and his plan for the winter and spring
also is to be gross
what happened to the ass napkins he
doesn't wear them anymore i think he
does but i don't know i
that's a guy who should be taking horse
dewormer if there's any person on the
planet
you want to know how jeff the drunk is
doing
um he is he wants to tell us you didn't
do a report but he's ready to report on
himself we actually ignored him on the
summer update
but he wants us to know how he's doing
okay hey jeff hello
hello i went to vegas but um
i had a bunch of health issues
all summer that's shocking
my right ear
is clogged shut
i just put my finger
and then there's like
a bunch of wax and so
i guess
paper towels i guess paper towels
david tell
what do you say about david texas
no he's saying paper towels oh
he took a lot of paper towels and rolled
him up and he stuck him in his ear and i
guess some of it didn't come out so that
was also in his ear i'm reading this
note i'm gonna throw up i'm debating
whether i read it jeff said the most
disgusting yellow green pus came out of
his ear oh
yeah you know hear what
dude do you clean your
all right hey well there's uh
jeff what were you doing in vegas with
all this going on you guys hired me he
got fired the day after i left
oh my god you're telling me a guy hired
you to come to vegas and appear at his
bar and the guy who hired you got fired
because of you yeah basically
but what what did you do
that got him fired
nothing
to find me
and then no one showed up for the meet
and greet
they flew them in they put them up in a
hotel they had a paper they probably had
shell out a couple of grand
yeah
and then plain fare
and beers
anything you do with jeff backfires as i
can tell you
if i own a bar
i would hire jeff to appear at the bar
across the street
and ruin their business
you